Since we're on the subject
of focus management,
let me show you another
really useful technique.
On most websites the main content is
usually not the first thing in the DOM,
instead we often begin with navigation,
sublists,
side bars, hamburger menus, and
other bits of page scaffolding.
This means that keyboard and screen
reader users must first navigate through
all of this content before they can
get at the actual heart of the page.
For users with motor impairments
this is especially frustrating.
A user who's unable to move
their arms might be navigating
the page with a switch device, which
they activate by tapping their head.
This user is going to have to tap
over and over again to get through
all of these elements before they can
get to our content, and that's not cool.
Thankfully, there's an easy to
implement solution to this problem.
Let's create a hidden link
that allows keyboard and
switch device users the ability to
jump straight to our page content.
These links are often
referred to as skip links.
Let me show you an example.
So here we are on the Funion news site,
and I have some navigation up here which
normally the keyboard user
would have to tab through.
Instead, when I press tab,
the first thing I'm presented with is
this little option up here in the top
of the corner, which is asking if I'd
like to skip down to the main content.
Pressing Enter will then move focus
down to the main content area,
bypassing all of our navigation.
Implementing a skip link
is actually really easy.
I'll start by creating a named anchor.
So the href of this anchor
refers to the ID of another element
that I'll have on the page.
I'm also going to give this
element a class of skip-link so
I can refer to it in CSS later.
I want the skip link to
appear early in the DOM, so
I'm going to put it
before my navigation.
To connect my skip-link to my main
content, I'll give my main element
an ID of maincontent,
which matches the href value up here.
So these two are now connected.
In newer versions of Chrome and Firefox
just doing this right here will allow
you to move focus down to the main
element when the skip-link is pressed.
But for older browsers which don't move
focus when named anchors are clicked,
I'm also going to want to
add a tabindex -1.
Over in my CSS, I'll make sure that the
skip-link has an absolute position, so
it can appear in the top
left corner of the screen.
But I'm going to make it
initially positioned off screen
by setting the top value to -40 pixels.
Then I can use the focus pseudo class
to move the element back on screen.
We'll talk more about the focus
pseudo class in a later lesson, but
the short explanation is that
this pseudo class matches
any time the corresponding
element gains focus.
With these simple techniques, we've
removed the road blocks from the path of
our keyboard users and
greatly improve their experience.
If you're interested to learn
more about other techniques for
creating skip-links, I'll leave a link
down in the instructor notes to a WebAIM
article, which covers
them in more detail.